alors nous sommes dans un mouchoir de
poche avec le front national c'est
encore indécis il reste un gros travail
à faire mais je peux vous dire que je
vais me mobiliser dès la semaine
prochaine autour d'hervé morin je serai
lundi à caen je serai jeudi à rouen la
victoire est à portée de main et c'est
une question de cohérence
nous avons regagné beaucoup de villes
aux élections municipales de 2014
notamment dans l'eure nous avons regagné
tous les départements au début de cette
année les cinq départements de la région
ont basculé à droite
mais si nous voulons avoir une politique
qui donne des résultats qui travaillent
dans le même sens
eh bien il faut maintenant que toute la
normandie bascule du côté de la droite
et du centre avec hervé morin